what are some of the like just most
incidental biggest surprises you've had
and Go in different places like places
that you might think you might not like
so much and then it ended up you really
did Tokyo vice versa Tokyo have you been
I have when you step off the plane in
Tokyo you step out into the city it's
like a giant pinball machine it's like
oh my God uh what's that that square
where the five roads meet uh ship uh
Shibuya yeah yeah if you're like oh I
think I should hide in my hotel like
Bill Murray in the movie right and you
and because you've seen the absolute sea
of humanity Crossing every time the
traffic like you've seen that a hundred
times and it's it's intimidating yeah
and when you realized
there's like a hundred of those squares
yeah in that City yeah and what is what
is the center what is what's happening
it's a pinball machine yeah yeah until
you have your first meal yeah
and you realize how perfect it is and
the lesson that you get rather quickly
is oh I can't control the outside but I
can true can't control the inside yeah
on every level yeah I I can take I take
what I can control and I make it as
perfect and beautiful as possible yes
that's the culture yeah and I fell in
love with it yeah and I got it so that
was the first big surprise to me yeah
because I hadn't been to that part of
the world at all that was the first time
did you had you did you like Japanese
food pretty well love yeah see me too I
I'll love love everybody by the way
we're lucky if you like sushi yeah we're
in LA with the best sushi towns in the
world I don't think I had better sushi
in Tokyo than I've had at the best
places here yeah I mean we have we have
so many amazing yeah spots yeah do you
want to say your favorite
um i i s I still really like uh well
there's some really good ones there's a
little one I live in Burbank there's a
little one in a strip ball in Burbank
called nishia yeah uh do you know that
one I don't it is in the back corner of
a little strip mall and uh it is
literally a mom-and-pop business I love
it a mom and pop Omakase and you tell
them you know you have any particular
things you do or don't like uh bring it
to me and then they feed you to your
full and you say okay stop you know but
I mean but there's no busboy there's no
there's just
the man and his wife and the you know
and they got to close down for a month
because they go back to Japan you know
you know it's just so that's like that's
great but as fancy one goes I still
matsuhisa
first place ever had sushi in L.A it's
in 1989 so yeah so fantastic it's still
great there's uh first place they have a
crab comma mache that we got once which
is like a kind of almost like a porridge
like a clay pot yes yes right crab in it
and that just spectacular one of those
things like one of those dishes that you
just remember
for the rest of your life you know I've
been a sushi zou so there's one in uh
Cheviot Hills and there's one downtown
now okay spectacular I'll remember yeah
because my son's you know my son's the
one my son I cannot say to my son hey
have you heard about this new you know
Congolese rice porridge place and he'll
be like yeah yeah I know that yeah I was
there I'm going to an Indian Italian
mashup in silver like tonight what wow
where like the the rigatoni is in uh
Masala wow wow sounds good right yeah it
does sound good it sounds like like a
fridge cleaning exercise you know what I
mean I hear it totally works yeah I can
I can't see why not yeah it's you know
sauces on on starches you know yeah and
then a curry like sauce Pizza yeah yeah
they have it see that's I I I just love
that you love food so much because I
just don't understand people I mean and
I probably love it too much you know uh
but I just don't understand people that
don't it's like not liking sex or
something yeah it's just not even used
to say oh you don't like music how do
you feel about colors yeah
[Laughter]
it's I just don't understand it's like
one of the things we gotta do why not
enjoy it yeah why not like
search out every little nook and cranny
of it to just to make it interesting and
make you feel alive and make you feel
like you know the alpha species on earth
like nobody else is listening you know
somebody else selfishly I automatically
because I love to travel my favorite
thing about traveling is the food I'm
gonna eat and I plan my trips around
absolutely where I'm gonna eat it
absolutely doesn't have good food
doesn't forget the show just life I'm
not going right because that's the main
thing I want to do is taste that culture
absolutely but then I realized it's
it's Universal it's everyone everyone we
all gotta eat first of all and I've yet
to meet a culture that hasn't told me
nobody eats like we do you come here
right right you're really good we agree
we have the most refined palettes on
Earth We're freak and we you don't want
you don't see any space between the
dishes on the table yeah yeah right yeah
or we're Italian you know we're gonna
eat oh we're Chinese you've never seen
it back but like this oh we're Jewish
yeah yeah yes
everyone yeah so yeah it's when you're
especially when you're uh doing a scene
with people and you want to hear about
them and their culture the food is this
great connector and then laughs of the
cement yeah yeah that's what we find
right that that if you we share a meal
and if it's good we're already a little
happier then when we came in and then if
we laugh now we're friends right so
that's the whole that's the whole thing
plug the the new version of the show
because it's you know somebody feed Phil
it's on Netflix uh there's five seasons
out right now and a sixth one is coming
in the fall and a book correct the the
companion book with recipes are 60 most
requested recipes from around the world
it's going to be one of the great
cookbooks not because of me right
because we got the best chefs in the
world to all give us recipes oh I gotta
get that you gotta get that do you cook
not at all not at all no and people say
how do you have a food thing and and you
know I said well listen I meet the great
chefs in the world that came around a
sitcom right right so we all contributed
our way and I couldn't be a bigger fan
yeah of theirs yeah yeah they need they
need me they like me because I love them
right right right I love to cook oh good
for you I cook I I have such respect for
anyone who can I it's you know it's it's
uh it can be almost like a meditative
things and there's sometimes there's
sometimes when I am
uh not necessarily feeling down but just
like I don't know there's stress anxiety
don't know what to do with myself and
I'll just be like ah I'm making a curry
you know and then you know and then you
have you know I live most of my
daughters with me half the time but you
know so there are I do now like why
we'll have Curry then for four meals but
but you know it's like it's still it's
pretty good and you know like Curry gets
even better as you leave it in the
fridge that's right yeah yeah I love
these Foods the the the the the street
foods the foods that came from
necessity yeah those are the most
delicious because they have to be
absolutely and what I love too and you
learn this is something that you see so
much with shows like yours
all this fancy schmancy you gotta have
this thing you gotta have this machine
you got to have that some of the best
food in the world is made by people that
cut things on their thumb that's right
with a a knife that's 60 years old and
they cook it in basically an aluminum
bucket you know it's like you don't need
fancy stuff to make delicious food you
can have any you know like I say the
best cooks in the world are cooking on
the cheapest stuff that you get at the
dollar store a dollar is what a bowl of
cow soy costs in Chiang Mai yeah at a
shack yeah that maybe I always talk
about it it's maybe the most delicious
thing I've ever had in my freaking life
yeah